he's adam feeling the vikings wide
receiver as we
catch up with him and uh he joins us now
how are you feeling pretty good
can't complain just uh uh got a little
conditioning in me before i got on the
show so
feeling good all right uh i'm looking at
what you guys did the vikings did your
2020 playoff teams
one and one versus the packers one and
one versus the bears
lost to the colts lost to the titans
lost to the seahawks
lost to the bucks lost to the saints so
two and seven there
best team that you faced this year is
who
um that's a great question
probably the bucks um just the way that
they were able to play defense get after
us
um you know get after the passer um they
got guys at every level on defense and
then the way that they're able to spread
the ball around on offense
and the weapons they have in office
offense is pretty impressive
okay give me that defense though uh
tampa's defense how impressive
yeah i mean i think i think it just
starts with the their their front seven
i mean the way that they're able to get
after the passer
the way that they're able to stop the
run fly around i mean uh obviously we
have a pretty good run game in minnesota
and uh man they're just able to fly
around and then and then in the back end
there are no slouches there so
um i think you know there's a few of
those teams i mean you look at the colts
very similar
um you look at you look at the packers
very similar i think those those playoff
teams that have
a chance to go a long ways they have
they have guys that can get after the
passer and they have guys in the back
end they can cover
so it's a good formula can you
root for the packers or do you like
because they're in your division
like do you want them to do well because
they're in your division
or do you have to root against them i i
don't necessarily root for or against to
be honest uh i just love watching
playoff football so i just i just love
watching
um kind of evaluating uh and
just watching close games so i'm just
hoping for some good football
i think there's going to be some great
games especially
you know tomorrow and sunday so it
should be fun to watch yeah but
let's say the gang is hanging in the
balance the bears have a chance to win
with a game-winning field goal
and you could you could swipe it one way
or another the bears beat the saints or
they lose in dramatic fashion
what would you do uh i i'd rather have
the bears win
you would yeah over the saints yeah
but they're in your division i know
but it is what it is but but you guys
have had issues with the saints before
uh and vice versa too but
right do you hate the packers like are
you programmed you grew up a vikings fan
are you programmed to hate the packers i
mean
let's just put it this way um there's
there's not another team i like beating
more than the packers
uh so it's but but it goes both ways
right like there's nothing worse than
losing to the packers so
um and they've had our number as of late
so um
but uh but yeah there's nothing better
than beating the packages especially at
lambo
but is there does it get chippy like to
is it different
they you know you know i wouldn't say it
gets chippy with them i think they're
pretty uh
um you know i got a lot of friends on
that team um i think a lot of those guys
are
are you know they're good football
players and they're good people so um
i i really enjoy playing against teams
that that have you know respect for one
another um
now at the end of the day yeah you want
to beat them and you want to beat them
bad
uh but still it's nice to have you know
mutual respect and
go out there pl and play a clean clean
football game so
i enjoy that um and probably why
why i'm not going to necessarily root
against any of those teams
have you ever had any interesting
conversations that continue throughout
the game
with the defensive back oh yeah
absolutely
um but i mean interesting or like
did they get does it get you know really
trash talk or somebody actually can
carry on a conversation with you
oh i think there's a little bit of both
uh depends on who you're playing uh
some guys uh i'm not gonna go into names
uh but some guys are
are a little weird with way they talk
like you know complimenting
um you know asking how the family's
doing
uh you know like almost like overly nice
uh so that's kind of weird
um
you don't really know right it's kind of
like a little bit of like over the top
and a little bit of maybe
uh but it's just kind of a weird like
head game maybe that they're trying to
play
and then you got the other side where
it's like way over the top the other way
like
you know saying that i'm going to punch
you in the face if you say a word uh
so which gets a little weird like you're
going to punch me in the face with the
helmet on uh
it's a little weird wait wait what what
what warrants getting punched in the
face
or somebody just say that to you that's
a great question that's why i think it's
it's weird and it's a little over the
top but well do they start the game by
say
feeling gonna punch you in the face
today
yeah like like uh plays over and you
know i'm
i cuz i like to you know talk a little
bit on the field you know have fun with
it
um and you know i i looked at the guy
and i'm like what are you why are you
talking right now like he was he was
talking smashing our teammate
he looked at me and said say a word and
i'll punch you in the face
i'm like all right man like i got a
helmet on like it punched me that's fine
um you know you start to look at the
vikings growing up and it was right in
your wheelhouse with
with moss and chris carter have you
talked to them
of about you know being a wide receiver
what goes into it yeah yeah no it was
pretty cool
i've been able to talk to them both have
pretty good conversations with them
um you know just talking football i did
an interview with randy moss a few years
back
and uh he didn't even necessarily want
to do the interview he just wanted to
talk ball which which i thought was
was fun and cool and uh you know he was
he was teaching me about uh some of the
things that he did to help the him and
his routes and things like that
i thought that was pretty cool do you uh
fanboy at all do you ask for jerseys
like when you face the saints or
brady with the buccaneers aaron rodgers
would you ask for a jersey for any of
from any of those guys
yeah you know it's it's kind of
interesting i like to do it you know
guys that i get to know
um you know play against a lot um you
know maybe get to know off the field for
sure
um i need to i need to ask some of those
guys for their jesus because i've got to
know a few of them but uh
but yeah you know if i don't really know
him it's kind of awkward and i'm sure
like you know
uh brady and rogers and those guys i
mean they get they probably get asked
by 15 people every game for their jersey
so i try to avoid that
uh but but hopefully if i you know you
build a relationship with them off the
field and
and maybe we'll get one one day but uh
but yeah it's just kind of a weird deal
when
you're talking to guys like that well
also you need to have the clubhouse guy
go over
and ask because you can't ask
because you don't want to be told no so
you'd rather the clubhouse guy went over
and asked for
aaron rodgers would you put up aaron
rodgers jersey
i would yeah uh aaron and i have got to
have a pretty good relationship so
uh definitely would because of our you
know off-the-field relation he loves to
play golf
i love to play golf so we played a lot
together in lake tahoe with the
tournament there and
um got to know him pretty well he knows
my family and all that so
uh definitely would put his up uh
packers saints buccaneers other who
makes the super bowl in the nfc
well um that's a tough one i think
i think uh it's between the saints are
not the saints uh the
buccaneers and packers if i were to if i
were a bet man that's who i would bet on
between those two i don't really know i
mean obviously they the first meeting
wasn't great between them
uh for the packers obviously uh but i
would
i would have to imagine uh you know
going to lambeau if those two
played each other that um that'd be a
lot better game so
so we'll see which defense would you
rather face
buccaneers of the packers i
would rather face i would rather face
the packers
because we were able to run the ball
pretty well against in the second
meeting
uh but uh but they're both very similar
to be honest
uh there's not much difference between
the two both
are both our top defenses in the nfl how
many minivans does kirk cousins have
has he has one van um but then the rest
of his cars are basically vans
he just strikes me as he's a minivan guy
he he he's not a minivan guy he's more
of like the astro man
um with like the the creepy curtains
um but uh but yeah he's he's he's an
interesting guy he's it's unbelievable
his uh he loves cars
um but will not spend the money on
buying a car
uh so he tries to get the best deals um
i think he has a deal back home with
with like a toyota dealership or
something or no i think it's a honda
dealership so i think he does have a van
back home from the honda dealership
hey it's great to talk to you
congratulations on the season there adam
we appreciate your time
all right i appreciate it thanks that's
adam thielen of the vikings